mr. president thank you so much for
taking the time to join us at Stanford
it's definitely an honor and a privilege
for us to host you here this is a very
important time for Rwanda celebrating 20
years after the genocide conflict and
for yourself it's a very important time
to you could consider that your terms in
office have been incredibly successful
and you continue to be successful in
transforming the Rwandan economy in fact
I have a quote from a recent IMF report
that states prudent fiscal and monetary
policies geared towards maintaining
macroeconomic stability coupled with a
strong emphasis on building
institutional quality promoting good
governance and creating a business
friendly environment contributed to low
inflation and average annual economic
growth in excess of eight percent over
the last decade from a regional
perspective Rwanda or one is
macroeconomic performance has generally
outperformed its peers now this is a
decade over which you have been in the
leadership and I'd love for you to tell
her students in your own words about
this economic transformation and what
was your vision and how did you see it
implemented what has been first of all
thank you for inviting me to be here but
this has been a very long and
challenging journey and that involves
wonders that's the most important thing
one of the wonders in the sense that
what we have tried to do when you come
to office is to make sure that we
mobilize violence so that together we do
whatever it takes for us to fulfill our
potential spiration and put in place the
kind of environment that
no facilitator that whether it was in
terms of creating as political stability
security for the people and putting in a
place institutional government that will
provide accountability and so on and so
forth this is what we've been trying to
do and fortunately and we built from
that firm foundation fortunately we as
we move forward we realize the good
progress is being made so in addition to
the dramatic growth you've experienced
you've also managed to improve
inequality we've seen reductions in
inequality in rwanda and reductions in
poverty levels in rwanda can you tell us
a bit how you've managed that balance
between growth and also reducing
inequality and were there specific
policies that that led to that yes as a
mission everything you have been doing
has been focused on how one and is
participate how do one and is benefit
necessarily to be able to achieve that
you have put in place structures and
framework of good governance that allows
this participation to happen so that's
how inequality has been reduced by and
through this participation and we have
targeted the ordinary people as the
primary beneficiary of whatever else is
being done in the country in fact to
give it numbers just between 2006 and
2011 we saw 1 million people get out of
poverty
through the kinds of investments and
these governance institutions who have
created and allow them to participate so
reducing inequality was the main aim and
you can achieve it by allowing people to
participate so they benefit from
whatever that is being done for their
own interests you so I'd like to talk a
bit about the role of foreign aid in
Rwanda development
you've been the beneficiary of quite a
bit of aid and you've had quite a bit of
support from from donors and can you say
what has been sort of the highlights of
receiving aid you've said in the past
that the primary purpose of aid should
be to ultimately work itself out so tell
us a bit how you see that and what have
been some pitfalls in the use of Aid and
in potentially other countries let me
try to clear the confusion in the
understanding or with what some people
have said when we have tried to explain
issues around 8 there is nothing wrong
with aid for as long as it serves the
purpose of getting people out of the
cycle of poverty and independence this
is this is very important therefore when
we have made criticisms about Aid and
how it is used
we are really referring to the fact that
and and the problem is on both ends one
is on the side of the donors maybe who
give aid without really respecting the
other side to say they know what they
want or let's work together with them
let's listen to them
and identify what really needs to be
done
people to get out of poverty and out of
this need perpetual need for aid and
move forward this is very important they
have been good at evading aid which is
fair enough
but they haven't been good at
identifying with the beneficence the
recipient cut people to say this is the
best way to target poverty and to get
people out of dependence that's one side
the other side also is on the recipient
part on countries in Africa mainly maybe
elsewhere
there is also focusing too much on
getting aid and just getting aid and
getting more aged without saying when we
get aid this is what we need to be doing
so that we stopped needing aid and be
able to stand on our own that's a big
problem on our side so what we have done
in our own case and together with the
people who provided it is to say look we
need to do things differently we can't
continue to be in the stage that has
been there for the last over 50 years
let's identify together let's hold each
other accountable on how aid flows to us
and how it is used and be able to
measure the outcome and see focus on the
results is what we are doing together we
are giving us the kind of benefits so we
have insisted on this and where there
has been good cooperation with the
donors and we have seen also this
behavior change and they apart for some
time now and where we have worked with
them on this basis
we have found good reserves and that's
what has gotta have been happening so
let me push you a little bit more on
that can you say specifically
international aid and agencies such as
the World Bank or the IMF are there
particular ideas that you have or
thoughts that you have on on their
participation in development in
countries it is a simple and it has
worked
we have told them beat the institutions
of countries that we have said respect
the recipients of aid and also
understand that they can identify with
you and they really know what they need
what they need to do with the money you
give them as long as you do that then
there is likely to be good progress
that's all have insisted on and we have
seen more accepted acceptance of that
and we have seen it work you know a case
that has worked we have seen change in
approach with a World Bank even with MA
for other institutions international
institutions who have seen change with
the countries in my own country who have
benefited from largely aid from United
Kingdom from European Union and the
Dutch virgins and so on and who have
assisted that and they have been
accepting that we need to elect that and
we have seen very good results which
maybe have been working in other places
as well are beginning to work in other
places as well
so as you're talking about other places
in recent years a number of other
African countries have experienced quite
exceptional growth Mozambique you
Ethiopia burkina faso can you tell us a
bit about how you see the region going
forward and what role you see for rwanda
in in sort of helping to integrate the
region really africa generally if you
look at other than hugh trouble spots in
different parts otherwise there is good
progress if you take the region of East
Africa that involves Kenya Uganda
Tanzania Burundi and Rwanda and through
integration through creating a common
market through allowing intra African
trade to take place within these
regional bloc's you may talk about other
regional bloc's like the West African
day cause you have others in the south
and so on and so forth
good progress is being made and in the
East African Community where Rhonda is
located we have seen tremendous progress
under Wanda is playing we are playing
our own part as part of this region
abroad and we share best practices
across the region we learn from what is
happening in other countries they learn
from what is happening in the country
and we are able to move for neck that's
how one place is its own part not only
do we make sure that we cut out the
reforms the necessary within our own
borders and do the best we can but we
also benefit from the others and also
share with the others what we are doing
continues to play a part in that way
so let's take this back to Rwanda for a
second can you tell us a bit about your
vision for the future of growth in
Rwanda 8% growth is a very high growth
rate to sustain and a lot of that has
been just rebuilding after the conflict
so what do you see is the future for
growth for Entrepreneurship in Rwanda
for for cultivating that business class
that you mentioned let me start by
giving you a picture of the demographics
in Rwanda we have under 20 years forming
50 percent of our population we have 71
percent under 30 now this is a huge
opportunity much as it constitutes it's
a challenge this youthful population is
very important and if we put it in the
general context of say the whole region
of West Africa or even across the
continent with the growing middle class
that comes with opportunities again but
it is still a huge potential investments
say in agriculture whole continent the
region my own country a huge opportunity
and potential in infrastructure the then
growing businesses that we require
developing a vibrant private sector all
these have limitless opportunities that
will go on for quite a long time invest
in railroads roads in energy
infrastructure it's huge
that allows this young
population if invested in properly for
education skills and entrepreneurship
I'm doing it upon your skills I think
it's going to be huge for a long time so
you've also mentioned where there's been
talk of developing a knowledge economy
in Rwanda can you he tell us a bit more
about that and the progress on that and
in particular the progress on
cultivating the talent for contributing
to that knowledge economy investing in
the people is the right thing in itself
for Wanda it's even another thing
because Nigeria will have people and are
not allowed with so much in terms of the
non natural resources people talk about
everywhere so for us really it's a it's
the main thing first of all even whether
you mean even if for those who have
natural resources they still need to
invest in the people and forever that's
the big mistake learn in some places
they may be happy with having oil and
minerals and all kinds of things and
forget about investing in people for us
we don't have those so we cannot even
afford to forget to invest in people so
our people the most important and that's
how the whole idea of saying we need to
invest the people we need to base our
economy on knowledge and skills and the
use of technologies and so on and so
forth for for us that's the way to so
I'm gonna change change gear a little
bit and bring this back to the
significance of this time twenty years
after the genocide
there's been incredible transformation
and growth and reconciliation what would
you say are something left to still be
done with regards to reconciliation
after the conflict I think the need for
reconciliation will take a long time for
probably generations we cannot
underestimate in any way the damage
caused to our society whose social
fabric has been completely Molesley
destroyed by the genocide we had in 1994
and the politics before that so what you
are trying to do today is make sure that
Londoners understand what went wrong in
our history and be able to correct that
but do that so many things have to
happen we have indeed to allow
consideration to take place at the same
time this is dragged back by also that
there is a need for justice and
accountability so the mix of - of course
delays what you can achieve over time
but in any case we have structured the
need for justice in such a way that it
does not become an impediment to
reconciliation but rather allow the
conciliation conciliation to take place
so it will take time takes time but
allowing reconciliation talking about
our past talking about our problems and
accepting our problems that we are the
ones in a way primarily behind all these
that happened even if external factors I
don't think we need to
we are so much under them because that
would do Nobu the Train and we need to
concentrate on accepting our
responsibilities taking responsibility
for our future and agreeing to work
together and really harness the
diversity in society and just say we are
we are different but we are for being
different you can also work together for
that's how we have approached it and as
long as we also continue with good
growth growth that feeds into the
general development of our people and
good governance the trousers or wonders
to participate I think we stand much
chance in being where we want to be in
the near future
and speaking of where you want to be in
the near future what is sort of your
hope for a successor and what do you
hope to complete in your term in office
before you leave well I look back and
see the challenges you have had in the
past and how far we have come
stabilizing the country and creating
institutions has been our aim to make
sure that these institutions outlive any
individual you see people get obsessed
with putting dates when you go and you
know why don't you go ever spend so much
time on this but anyway let me tell you
I'm one of those who realized that even
if I didn't want to go I would go anyway
sometime I mean it's just natural that
having a program not to imagine that
time so that's what makes us feel this
need for institution to be built that
will outlive all of us so but back to
the specific question what I would want
to see what we have is continuation of
what we've already seen that we have
done together with continue and get
better so that wonder is digging T is
really fulfilled and achieved and that's
what is happening by the way across
Africa I think dignified the life that
people must leave has been lacking and
has been underlying most of these
problems you see so as long as we can do
that we can achieve that continue to
work towards achieving it I think I will
be happy that Wanda didn't fight people
stable country prosperous and continuing
to be part of the African continent and
Rwanda Africa really finding their own
voice and place in the global faith
which it doesn't have for a long time
and can you talk about the role of women
in Rwanda and sort of your push towards
encouraging women and how do you see how
do you see progress on that going
forward let me say that we look at the
role of women in the wider context and
of our countries our nationís
development women a pattern Passover
nation and society so they've got rights
to you know to aspire to as well but if
we look at 52 percent of our population
being women one would not be needed to
be so intelligent to understand that
this is part of a population you cannot
ignore and even on top of that being
there right so that's where our
understanding and our actions stem from
and we've seen women in education in
governance institutions decision making
their numbers decrease to the Parliament
in the judiciary in the leadership about
45% in the general administration
significant number business they're
beginning to pick up and the numbers are
increasing and it's it's helpful for our
country for our politics and for our
development so let me ask you a bit
about your leadership of Rwanda and your
leadership style and especially for
Business School students here they're
all interested in being leaders in the
future at least so we hope
tell us a bit about what you think most
prepared you for leadership in Rwanda
and if you have any advice for the MBA
students here and I should say all
students here because we've got more
than MBA students here I think many
problems have grown through prepared me
maybe 50 percent
okay try to do well through many of them
but the other part maybe I don't know
its nature which no one is responsible
for so maybe it is split 50-50 one is
the environment the other is nature and
combined will make person work so in my
environment of decades of hardships to
manage and live in and so forth I I
think they were not wasted they must
have formed something in a million so
but and in some cases I have found
myself in the positions of leadership
even when I have not made the choice to
be there just happens I find myself in a
place and being told them they want to
deal with the problems so it went has
come my feeling and my reaction has
always been to take on the challenge and
do the best one human area can and and
make sure you don't do it alone
you want to do it alone you don't want
to do it at all because it will break
your back if you really do that so you
try to make sure you share the burden
with others and get to understand each
other and where you are coming from and
what you have to deal with and then
agree what you want the outcome to be so
it's something that works in day-in
day-out and for as long as you want to
participate in what you are doing and
then you also realize you are in a
leadership position you've got to be
ready to carry the
challenges and the budgets that come
with it thank you and thank you for
sharing your thoughts so far we're now
going to open it up for a few questions
we're going to start with taking two
questions one from my left and then one
from my right and mr. president will
answer the first two questions and then
we can if we have time for more we'll
take some more so may I have the first
question from the left my left please
and please remember to state your name
and and tell us a little bit about
yourself hello President Kagame my name
is Cara record I am an undergraduate
political science major here at Stanford
my question is can you tell us a little
bit about what Rwanda is doing and
perhaps what it can do better in terms
of regional cooperation and specifically
human rights promotion and particularly
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
where millions of people have been
killed in the past 20 years at least in
part due to Rwandan involvement thank
you
but if we really want to understand the
region issues between Rwanda and and DRC
history and the roots I think I would
encourage you as a political science
student to visit Belgium and ask the
Belgians the progress because the
problems in the Congo started before I
was born
the first secretary-general of the UN
died in the Congo that is probably when
I was three four five years old so if
you really want to make a good study of
political science and the history that
give rise to many things that happen you
need to start from there and to fulfill
the human rights obligations I want to
take you again through what we do in our
own country all these things we are
talking about you are empowering women
when you're investing in education of
our people and covering every person and
making sure they have access and can go
to school if we give them healthcare
tasks universal health care that covers
close to 90% of our population if we're
investing in broadband and other
communications infrastructure that we
have very tall people so they can access
information and can communicate if we
have descender eyes it our politics the
point that the sectors the districts and
everybody can
access information can give their views
can that does not add up so I encourage
you to do your maths as you say here and
make sure that you will see that these
things we are talking about add up to
actually making sure that we encourage
unrealized respect for people's human
rights and we can't be doing it at home
and then not want to do it elsewhere
unless something is missing so as we do
what we do at home we share it with the
rest of the region and that's how it
happens in this tough Rican community if
you ask across the border so but the
history of Congo and all the other
issues they have the wrong history we
can go the whole day talking about that
but I don't think we have the time thank
you
we'll take a question from this side
Thank You mr. president my name is Ken
Apollo I'm a PhD candidate in the
Department of Political Science my
question is on the issue of term limits
in Rwanda Oh term limits okay
presidential term limits you said that
you're not obsessed with specific dates
but you know institutional development
is also predicated on having specific
and very obvious term limits so that
everyone knows those specific dates so
what what what is it what is your take
on term limits in Rwanda and do you like
the idea of having your retirement date
set yeah clearly thank you see what I
was referring to and you know I have
been asked this question since I came to
office in 2000
and I've always tried to figure out what
is in it today and yet at the same time
everyone who stands up to asking me this
question refers to the time limits that
exist in the Constitution so what did
they really are they asking
so shall I rephrase
I think what we are talking about here
is something that primarily concerned is
abundance can you please respect their
oneness
and allow them a chance to do what they
feel is good for them if they put a
constitution in a place it is their
constitution if they are talking about
President Kagame he is their president
they're the ones who elected him I did
not write in the Constitution I don't
write constitutions so there shouldn't
be you know we can't take all the time
talking about are you going when are you
going which date do you were the only
one to go and they say so now I think it
has come to a point to say why don't you
wait and come 2017 we see what will
happen that's the only the best thing we
can do otherwise
I'm even being distracted from I still
have some close to three years to serve
I want to deliver to my people and not
to keep answering whether I'm not there
to leave to stay out know I'm there to
deliver to my people period all these
other things are just a sideshow really
if you didn't to waste anybody's time
because in any case
everyone knows whoever is asking this
question they may not finally decide
what happens
it is the one man is literally decide to
force Kagame to respect the concision
they put in place in case he misbehaves
and in thinking about something else and
so on and so forth
so let's let's let's respect what is
there its respective it's let's talk
about two other very important issues
with that let's take one more question
I'll take one from the middle if there's
a microphone thank you my name is
Kennedy Joe Walker I'm a Ugandan
journalist well we know that South Sudan
has fallen kind of apart after a very
very fast kind of a period where you
know leaders trying to put it together
and build this state to make sense in
that very troubled region and I'm
wondering what your thoughts are for a
robust African Union kind of team Army
in a way going to South Sudan and trying
to keep the peace there because I think
it's one of the countries that if
African leaders allow it to fall as it
is right now might cause a lot of
trouble in the region so I wonder if you
have any thoughts on that
and if you would like to share that my
name is Kennedy Joe Walker Kennedy
Kennedy thank you very much for your
question why don't we take one more
question so that you can answer both at
the same time in the interest of time
just to make sure we do get to at least
one more question yes my name is Pro
Joel I'm a second year MBA student at
the GSB it's hard not to compare ruinous
transformation to that of Singapore and
and the two things that strike me are a
a small population size as well as the
fact that there had to be time given to
a president for several decades to sort
of sort of execute on the vision that
they had so my question is
a how scalable do you think what you've
done with Rwanda is to countries with
larger populations and be in a place
like Southeast Asia there's room for
only one Singapore so we think about
East Africa and Africa in general can
Rwanda end up being is Singapore of
Africa and be a hub for innovation and
entrepreneurship in the region while the
rest of region to other words around it
the first question is how scalable do
you think is the transformation that
that you've undertaken in Rwanda in
countries with larger populations and
and is is the transformation constrained
by how big a country is let me start
with this one first of all the African
Union the aim is actually to create on
the part of the force for example there
has been an aim of creating what we call
a standby force for therefore Africa but
this was to be divided across regions
southern Eastern Central Western so at
each region countries they bring
together their capacities in order for
them to be able to intervene when that
is necessary to say in the part of the
in any part of the region all the
regions to come together irrespective of
where the trouble is meaning south and
east and central can work together to
deal with the problem in eastern South
and Africa thus that's that's what has
been agreed and put on paper in fact to
a great extent some countries have
already advanced on that right in the
East African community there has been
progress but not enough to cut out the
intervention like that required in
southern Sudan the problem is much
bigger probably than what has been put
together through this organization but
the aim is there the principle is there
understandings they're wrong the rhymes
you are talking about but the problem of
South Sudan is also there now it can't
wait until Africa gets better and
improves in another 10 years or
whichever it he needs intervention now
and that's how it has now reverted to
the UN the UN is thinking about what to
do and has already put forces on the
ground small size not able to deal with
a challenge that is on the ground in
fact one is already has a battalion in
South Sudan trying to help under the UN
but at the same time we also have the
force in the central freakin Republic so
it is steer countries on individual
bases that are being called upon either
under the a you like because like in the
center African Republic the first
started as that under the African Union
but now the UN has taken over
responsibility and they are mobilizing
more forces not only from Africa but
beyond so that's how things are
the thinking is that the need is there
the principle is the correct one but the
implementation still is dependent on the
capacities of different countries to be
able to do what they are required to do
that capacity is lacking so do you take
a bit of time that's why every time we
want we wait for the UN because you any
kind pour resources from across the
world rather than just from one part of
the continent on the second question the
first one is in bends on how you want to
look at it countries with bigger
populations
one can also look at it as that being
more sources to put to problems and so
it depends there on a number of things I
think the most important thing is how
have we invested in people
how are you ready to mobilize the people
around this program to find a solution
what are the kinds of resources you need
and were they going to be drawn from so
for the conflict one where maybe in
comparison with the Singapore's on so
forth what you can do in one small
country with a big problem this is
another thing being small does not mean
you can't have big programs so everyone
is small but it has had huge programs
which may be big countries don't even
have so but that in I think the approach
the approach of investing in people in
the right you know sectors business
private sector infrastructure skills and
so on and so forth and then the actual
management of that the governance of
that is very critical but this can be
scaled up for you know bigger countries
I think the populations in my view you
have more resources for example when we
are trying to make sure that our country
can regenerate and increasingly so the
the internal revenues from activities of
the people who have 12 million but I
think places with a hundred million
have million people they have maybe 10
times more opportunities as where to
grow from given what these human beings
can contribute so I think it is a scarab
or what has been used in Rwanda in
Singapore in other places I think can
can be done as well and you've also
talked about freedom of labour mobility
so people can come in immigrants can
come in so that contributes to having a
greater workforce you've also talked
about increased trade integration so
although certainly contribute to the
scalability absolutely what environment
you create yes for us we have
realistically you know understood and
accepted problems uniqueness as the
country the way we are landlocked and
smaller populations and so forth and we
found solutions around that and one way
with the shortage of skiers because of
many things in history including this
genocide we are talking about and so on
and so forth we couldn't and of course
even initially even before the tragic
situation we had a small skilled
workforce but we had ambitions and more
opportunities to build fast and move on
and we couldn't wait until you have
developed invested in own people because
investing in some of the skills required
in the people takes many years so we had
to accept that we can allow people from
outside to come and work in Rwanda and
it's a win-win kind of situation but
around that again we had to make sure
there is something unique we create
about 200 to make it attractive that's
the security that's transparency that's
about
accountability issues in Iran and
fighting corruption and so on and so
forth so that even in doing business
when we say well when you come true and
and you want to invest and you want to
start a company you take you six hours
to open a company initially it was
taking us in 90 days in some places to
stay like that so if somebody is to wait
for 90 days to open a company country
and they're saying no if you come I'll
be done with everything in six hours I
think they prefer to come for six hours
instead of the cost of 90 days very good
so we have time for one more quick
question and let's see where the mic is
and we'll take one from the middle hi
mr. president my name is Bowen and I'm a
second year MBA student my question is
around your views on the increasing aid
and money from China especially in the
context alpha China's growing prominence
around the world in the context of of us
is international policies in Africa
thank you well that's not a quick
question but
I will allow the president to say what
he can in two minutes
well China yes big size worth and so on
and wanting big a stake in the globe
Affairs comes with some responsibilities
so but China has been maybe meeting its
responsibilities through private
investments across Africa and because of
their role in the international
financial institutions other countries
that have a bigger stake they're telling
them to step up and increase their
participation in terms of how much money
they put in there that we later on work
across different parts of the world I
think this is this is fine this this
should be the case but anyway wherever
the money comes from or whatever
participation we just need to think
about what is this participation how
healthy is it to the recipients and also
to the needs their needs as well as
those who are giving money give money
not giving it for free I know they they
expect a certain either profits or
feedback or benefits of some kind so we
have to look at the formula that
satisfies all sides thank you so much
you